I'm just a girl standing in front of you
with full hair makeup and the
WrestleMania shirt from WrestleMania
2017 asking you to allow me to judge
people there very much better at fashion
and lifestyle than I am
no I mean if you're so big if you do not
know now you know your life is different
now the Met Gala has gala I love our
goddamn faces and it's time to review
the fashion this is the red carpet
fashion event to end all other red
carpet fashion events and if you don't
know I love doing red carpet fashion
reviews so it's the perfect combination
if you're unfamiliar with the Met Gala I
also do not fully understand exactly
what it is it's the fanciest Outback
Steakhouse of fashion there are no rules
and no one's right I'm already stressed
and excited X dress that makes it sound
slightly positive or like a 90s hip-hop
group the theme of this year's Met Gala
is heavenly bodies fashion and the
Catholic imagination I mean all of
Catholicism it's really just a figment
of our imagination everyone can believe
whatever they want to believe I believe
it's a good idea for me to talk about
fashion so we all make choices some of
them are mistakes segue into let's
talking about these red carpet Met Gala
fashions so this theme obviously has
direct connection to religion which is
often very polarizing or controversial
subject to be talked about and I have to
preface this video because I have to now
with the fact that I admire everyone
that shows up to an event like this
Ian's clothes that are cumbersome and
not meant to be worn on the human body
there is no disrespect no thing on
anyone this is just a very pure
optimistic review of the fashion circus
that is the Met Gala that's my dog
groaning but also you know foreshadowing
for how you're gonna react to this video
so many people went to the Met Gala this
year and there are so many looks being
served
it's a goddamn all-you-can-eat buffet
because the service is unending I know
it'll probably not talk about someone
that you want me to talk about or look
at a review so I tweeted out asking for
you guys to send me
some of your favorite looks and they're
so goddamn many that we're gonna try and
fly through them I mean some might say
there are as many looks served as there
are indiscretions in the Bible okay I'm
done Liza Koshi Isaac oh she is wearing
this adorable Wednesday from The Addams
Family got a makeover outfit and then
well BAM
it must be the Last Supper cuz she's
serving rump roast right now and she
looks great doing it good job Liza Co
she cute Shailene Woodley looks like a
slightly uncomfortable like private
school fembot soldier that also models
for like space Abercrombie & Fitch yeah
Greta Gerwig why not this is enough
fabric to make like a full blimp and
this is like full Flying Nun get it girl
this is like a classy high-end editorial
nun Snuggie and I'm here for amen I
gotta stop making those kind of but I
won't stop I'm sorry I can't stop like
Jesus oh wait he stopped you don't we
grab it Oh
let there be leg this is like the
sexiest doily I've ever seen Troye Sivan
oh my god Christ has died Christ is
risen and guess what Christ just came
again because Christ has a huge crush on
Troye Sivan and looking at him in this
outfit ayoh
who wouldn't come again I am really
offending a lot of people I'm sorry I
respect everyone Madonna I mean this is
just Madonna on a Tuesday this is
Madonna it's like she woke up and she
checked her you veidt's and was like
shocked it's the Met Gala and then it
was already sleeping in this and so just
showed up Janelle Monae can do no wrong
to me at any red carpet event ever ever
and this included like a glamor Crusader
that was fighting for like the right
side of history and then was like I need
to get my print slash Celine Dion
backwards tuxedo thing but we're at
frontwards and get to the Met Gala keep
my chainmail just keep the chainmail I
don't want to worry about my hair I love
it Bella Hadid telehealth did you get
into that
ensemble good job dude i'ma tell ray and
jared leto you guys look like two tarot
cards and I'm here for it 70s Dumb and
Dumber tuxedo situation means a herd
emic meets why that's not cute Sarah
Michelle Gellar and Andy Cohen if you
don't know go to the Met Gala every year
and Sarah Michelle Gellar is like the
queen of the net gala
she always shows up with looks and yeah
she Wow Alice in Wonderland meets the
actual Vatican meets Big Ben meets like
sexy Hugh Hefner Matador chic and why
not yeah this is decadent and subtle so
subtle cute Emilia Clarke from Game of
Thrones I love this I love you I mostly
love photos of people fixing elaborate
outfits on fashion carpets so I really
appreciate this on a lot of levels you
know it took a lot of judging like this
to get that photo of the Last Supper so
a little behind the scenes inside Scoob
yeah Jaden Smith you will always be
seated at the right hand of his father
what are you thinking about it Jesus was
all about grassroots promotion you're
just in the streets screaming about all
the things that he could do so Jaden
Smith okay look brought his own Bible it
seemed to work there's a pretty big
following for Jesus stuff he did it look
you could do it too ariana grande you
look like the Sistine Chapel sis you
look like a teen Chapel this is like a
work of art I also love it in every
photo Oh Ariana on the carpet her
posture is so demure it's as if she's
either channeling her inner like goddess
or the bow on her head somehow got
tucked into like her thong and she
literally cannot lower her chin either
way got it I got it
Oh Donald Glover I mean the Lord and
Savior himself is there and needs no
review he's perfect and divine and
hopefully going to save all of our dirty
souls yeah Blake Lively Wow amazing that
she wore the tablecloth from the Last
Supper to the Met Gala totally on theme
love it and also how did you get anyway
Met Gala happens in New York I can't
even like get myself in and out of a cab
with just my backpack on hat what also
you guys spill red wine all night and
it's not gonna matter so perfect color
choice cute Nicki Minaj Wow
also your face looks like you just found
out that your dress is prank - and you
didn't realize that it was this big the
whole time you're on the carpet but well
I mean this is really the body aadhi
aadhi of Christ Sunday is daya
I've always stop pronouncing your name
but I am Zen dead up because this is
being awesome
chainmail soldier glamour Jonah bar
you've single-handedly rebranded what
we've all come to hate that is chain man
you've got chain mail and god dammit I
wish I did - Jesus Christ you Katy Perry
another very subtle moment at the Met
Gala guys want to know what Victoria's
Secret is she's Catholic and this is the
reason the Met Gala is as dumb and fun
as it is how did you get out of your car
how did you get into the event do you
guys see any photos of Katy Perry like
awkwardly trying to get in and out of
doorways because of this outfit please
let me know it's like when you see
someone that goes to like a Comic Con
and their dress is like Megatron or like
you know that's all I know and their
cosplay is super [ __ ] impressive but
then you watch them like try to handle
like three stairs and it's very very
humiliating I mean how she's even
sitting like this is nuts
Plus this reporters face it's pretty
great
Kim Kardashian the Kardashians in
general are a powerhouse at the Met Gala
and this is pretty you know subdued for
kids maybe that's the point I don't know
I missed the days of sofa Kim's I might
say I'm so [ __ ] sad that we don't
have those Met Gala days anymore do
cardi be my yeah literally you are my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
I'm truly having a religious experience
this is amazing I love everything about
this it's like if the Pope transitioned
and then got married this would be his
wedding dress and I [ __ ] love it
Nielsen twins honestly I do not believe
that this photo is from this Met Gala
this could be from any red-carpet event
that they have been to at all in the
last 10 to 15 years can't mock us mock
you Rihanna the Pope has arrived
bless us O Lord for these thy gifts
which you're about to receive from thy
bounty through Christ our Lord amen
Jesus cry pop hot look great no one I've
attic can't handle this and I've got a
confession is it apostle all to look
this good you Frances McDorman I love
this woman so much this is probably very
own theme I don't know how or why I want
her to wear this to every goddamn award
show every event this is her face protip
you don't have to worry about your hair
and makeup if you go to event just up
like your mid confetti cannon dad she's
so much better than all of us
Lena waves holy [ __ ] this is so good I
just love everything you are and
everything you do yeah Diane Kruger wow
this is like Vatican level toilet paper
stuck in the back of the pants you
Hailee Steinfeld steamed the experience
Haley's things this is very like if
Jesus had a stepdaughter and it was her
goddamn super sweet 16 yeah girl
chadwick boseman if we want to talk
about God's gift I mean this is God's
gift so cute okay guys that is my Mecca
a fashion review I know I missed a ton
of people that you might have wanted me
to talk about but leave comments down
below who your favorite look was there
are so many if you liked this video give
it a thumbs up and do not forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel I'm
trying to post a couple videos a week
we'll see how it goes you know nothing
in life is certain jesus said he was
coming back okay gotta stop this I don't
know
jail oh yes yes yes yes yes you pick a
goddamn stained-glass window and some
old-ass Church in Europe and then
somehow like a black bear burst through
it and if that isn't what Catholicism is
I don't know what is yeah